[Musique]
vous sentez-vous joyeux qui ici se sent
joyeux dans sa vie lever la main ouais
d'accord
autre question qui pensent que la joie
est de notre responsabilité individuelle
lever la main ouais ça va c'est à peu
près la moitié on va dire ok drôle
d'association de mots responsabilité
versus joie n'est ce pas la
responsabilité
c'est là le devoir de répondre de ses
actes et la joie c'est un sentiment un
plaisir et un bonheur intense que l'on
ressent quand on vit quelque chose de
fort et qui nous correspond autrement
dit nous aurions à répondre de notre
joie waouh il faudrait donc arrêtez de
râler de ressasser de ruminer et
commencer à créer sa joie sacrément
ambitieux je suis responsable de ma joie
j'en suis l'architecte et ce n'est pas
mon boss mes collègues les actualités ou
les événements que je vis qui me rende
ma joie c'est moi et moi seul qui décide
de comment cultiver ma joie j'ai appris
de façon intuitive une règle de fuite de
psychologie on appelle la règle des 90
10 et qui dit que la réaction que nous
avons que nous choisissons d'avoir face
aux événements a beaucoup plus d'
influence sur nous et sur nos vies que
les événements eux-mêmes
je viens d'une famille bourgeoise
traditionnel où l'excentricité pas
vraiment de mise
éducation religieux chez les bonnes
soeurs repas dominical en famille
vacances dans la maison de famille en
bord de mer bref peu de place à la folie
et aux sorties de route
mon père s'appelle olivier il est il
aime la littérature et les écrivains
il aime la musique classique tennis
formule 1 plutôt sportif mais devant sa
télé pas bricoleur pour deux sous
très bons danseurs de rock et de valses
et surtout il aime rire il est mort à 48
ans d'un cancer me dit-on jusqu alors
j'ai 18 ans nous sommes le jeudi 14
novembre 1991
j'apprends au lendemain de son
enterrement
il était homosexuel et qu'en réalité il
est mort du sida
imaginez-vous pendant 18 ans vous vous
êtes construite sur un mensonge
comment ne pas être en colère ne pas se
sentir trahi frustré abandonné vous
réalisez votre famille n'assume rien
pour l'homosexualité est une maladie et
le sida est honteux
voire même contagieux rappelez vous que
dans les années 90
rien que de se faire la bise beaucoup
pensé qu'on pouvait être contaminé ma
vie dit elle alors fondé sur une vaste
fumisterie de notre petite enfance à
notre adolescence nous nous imprégnons
des croyances des règles et des attentes
de notre famille les rendant bien
souvent plus importante que ce que nous
voulons est ce que nous ressentons
j'endosse et je reproduis pendant des
années un mensonge
une honte concernant mon père qui ne
sont pas les miens je me fais des noeuds
à la tête au coeur tout ça est très
lourd trop lourd et un jour j'ai dit
stop
j'ai décidé d'arrêter de perpétuer le
mensonge de ma famille
l'histoire de mon père ne sera pas un
frein à ma vie je refuse de le juger
je laime tel qu'il est mieux l'histoire
de mon père sera une chance dans ma vie
vas-y ma fille ne te cache pas
cultive-t-on être intérieur soit qui tu
es en vie d'être réveille-toi être est
plus important que par être que jouer un
rôle pour plaire ou pour répondre à des
codes de société en changeant mon regard
est mon ressenti sur cet événement somme
toute douloureux je laisse la joie
prendre sa place la vie s'illumine dès
nuage disparaisse et le ciel s'éclaircit
je décide de ne garder que les valeurs
positives de cet événement la tolérance
le respect l'ouverture d'esprit la
bienveillance et la résilience comment
alors avec de telles valeurs positives
ne pas cultiver sa joie au quotidien une
sclérose en plaques pour beaucoup est
synonyme de fauteuils roulants de
handicap de perte d'autonomie
l'indépendance
et pourtant c'est cette maladie comme le
diagnostic il ya quelques années je sais
ça ne se voit pas et pourtant ma coloc
elle est bien là et j'ai un bail à vie
avec elle la sclérose en plaques est une
maladie auto immune qui atteint système
nerveux central cerveau et moelle
épinière
elle peut aboutir à une perte de
motricité de la vue et plein d'autres
trucs pas très très cool et elles se
manifestent sous forme de pouce est
différente d'un malade à l'autre j'ai
fait trois poussées en 12 ans sans
séquelles ouf
et à chaque fois j'ai subi des
paresthésies dans les jambes à quoi on
ajoute une bonne grosse fatigabilité en
2005 au diagnostic direct
j'ai appelé la ligne directe du ciel de
l'univers j'appelle bosse j'ai appelé
dieu et je lui ai dit mon père vient
déjà de mourir du sida il ya quelques
années ma mère vient tout juste de
décéder d'un cancer
et voilà que moi on m'annonce que j'ai
une sclérose en plaques
est ce que par hasard un message en
particulier à me transmettre la
troisième poussé bien que violentes les
salvatrice bien que violentes et
douloureuse a été salvatrice
bon je rappelle quand même là où parce
qu'il faut quand même pas exagérer
faut pas abuser des bonnes choses ont
une fin et c'est là que je prends du
temps pour moi que je prends rendez vous
avec moi même que je ralentis je décide
de prendre le temps d'écouter ce que mon
corps mon coeur et mon âme essaye de me
dire je découvre le décodage biologique
et la mémoire cellulaire nos peurs nos
croyances induite par nos familles notre
culture notre milieu social nous limite
tout est inscrit dans nos cellules et
rien et immuable nous avons le pouvoir
de changer cette programmation afin de
ne pas renouveler les mêmes schémas
il n'y a qu'a réalisé à l'extérieur ce
que l'on veut être le yoga du rire vous
connaissez c'est l'autre technique que
je découvre alors et à laquelle je me
forme rire sans raison
rires pour se détendre pour se relaxer
du rire aux larmes et des larmes au rire
c'est comme être libéré délivrés excusez
moi je chante extrêmement faut qu'il
faut pas que je m'emballe il ya des gens
qui sont de meilleurs que moi
est ce que vous savez ce que l'on
célèbre le 20 mars à travers le monde
c'est la journée internationale du
bonheur bon je fais la maligne mais en
2014 je ne le savais pas et pourtant
par un heureux hasard sous sommes
toutefois les hasards existe c'est ce
jour là que je décide d'animer ma
première séance
mon premier atelier du rire pendant plus
d'une heure des gens que je ne connais
pas ils ne me connaissent pas vont vivre
une expérience
l'expérience de l'instant présent les
oublie tous les devoirs des enfants qui
ne sont pas faits
la dispute avec leurs conjoints ce matin
le boss qui les soude un petit peu les
bouchons sur la route ils se détendent
ils lâchent prise mieux en se connectant
à leur âme d'enfant et en la laissant
s'exprimer
il tisse des liens entre eux qu'est ce
que c'est beau de voir des étoiles de
joie briller dans le regard des gens
qu'elle kiffe transmettre cultiver
partager la joie autour de soi c'est une
évidence
tellement évident que l'on m'appelle
très rapidement pour animer des
conférences
aujourd'hui mon activité professionnelle
c'est la joie je suis alchimiste de la
joie j'interviens dans des séminaires
très très sérieux de cadres managers et
de chefs d'entreprise ou la joie et les
rires sont pas vraiment toujours
attendus
et je leur fait prendre conscience que
cultivaient la joie et de leurs
responsabilités pour eux mais aussi pour
leurs équipes et je les titillent un
petit peu avec des jeux avec des rires
avec des questionnements vous par
exemple
la dernière fois que vous avez vécu un
moment difficile
désagréable sans pour autant en passer
par une maladie ou un deuil
simplement les bouchons sur la route les
factures qui s'accumulent et n'arrive
peut-être payé ou ce genre de choses
comment avez vous réagi la prochaine
fois vous vivez une difficulté une
désillusion une contrariété
choisissez qu'allez-vous faire rester
dans l'amertume la colère la peur la
tristesse et subir les événements ou
bien décider vous de vous ouvrir à
d'autres possibilités et agir il y à
qu'a créé à l'extérieur ce que vous avez
simplement vous choisir de l'état dans
l'aide dans les caves dans lequel vous
voulez être et je suis certaine
je vois pas tous mais que voulez tous
est dans la joie et la bonne humeur
la belle a là rien et immuable chat de
chaque événement que vous vivez vous
pouvez apprendre quelque chose de
positif et de ce positif
vous pouvez cultiver votre joie chaque
l'expérience nous apprend que nous
sommes les créateurs de nos vies les
créateurs de notre joie vous êtes toutes
et tous des alchimistes de votre vie des
alchimistes de votre joie
vous pouvez tous transformer le plomb de
votre vie en or vous n'avez besoin de
personne et encore moins besoin
d'attendre quelque chose pour agir
c'est où vous voulez quand vous voulez
avec qui vous voulez en gros c'est qui
le patron
merci
la distance entre la peine et la joie
est immense à franchir citons accepte
qu'elle le reste
dixit le docteur christian louis et je
valide carrément ce qu'il dit je vous
invite maintenant à vivre une expérience
insolite et fun championnat qui commence
à voir venir première vérité que je vais
vous a cédé en cette fin de journée
savez vous que votre cerveau est bête
alors je sais c'est un tout petit peu
violents annoncés comme ça mais votre
cerveau ne fait pas la différence entre
harry rejouer sans raison et à rire
partagé entre amis ou en famille si vous
décidez de rire ici maintenant sans
raison de jouer le rire votre cerveau
déclenché les mêmes effets que pourra
rire naturel il va déclencher un show
d'endorphines du bonheur vous imaginez
quand même vous avez ce pouvoir de vous
chouchouter de voudriez quand vous
voulez où vous voulez simplement en
décidant de rire comme ça d'un
claquement de doigts alors comme je
voudrais vous faire vraiment vivre
l'expérience je vais vous demander de
vous lever alors on va on va faire un
petit échauffement parce que je sais
aussi que ça fait longtemps là vous êtes
assis et que voilà donc je vais vous
demander de tout faire comme moi est-ce
que vous êtes prêts à faire tout comme
moi il y en a qui sont déjà en train de
tout faire pour moi fabuleux vous êtes
prêt à vous déconnecter de là haut pour
vous connecter dans votre corps c'est
fabuleux faut vraiment tout comme moi
c'est magnifique
alors pourquoi le premier exercice nous
allons prendre nos petites mains non
nous n'allons pas prier je vous rassure
avec moi oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
autre exercice surmas complique un peu
de cela c'est un peu facile c'est d'âge
de quatre ans donc voilà vous êtes
toujours la même chose mais attention
pas vraiment la même chose que moi après
o o aaa au au aaa
oh oh oh oh oh ah ah ah oh oh ah ah ah
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ayala 3 qui suivent à bord vraiment
formidable avant bravo avec moi un
formidable
bravo bravo formidable donc ça c'était
le premier exercice deuxième exercice
vous avez tous en vous ce que je vous ai
expliqué un moteur du rire et vous avez
tous la clé donc vous prenez tous votre
clé du rire voilà parfait et ça fait ça
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh
bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo bien donc
ça c'était l'échauffement maintenant on
va passer aux choses sérieuses parce que
là voilà c'était simple alors mesdames
vous allez tout imaginer que vous êtes
l'acsm une actrice célèbre glamour voilà
celle que vous voulez dans votre tête et
messieurs vous êtes l'acteur le plus
sexy de hollywood ou de france et de
navarre et nous à vous avez une scène de
rire à jouer ça vous parle pas alors je
vais vous montrer comment on fait et
bien après on va faire tous ensemble
d'accords donc la scène de rire ça va
donner ceci j'imagine en mécène de rire
il faut que je règle est donc ça fait
[Rires]
mais alors je sais je vois bien même si
vous êtes loin de ça j'ai l'air ridicule
mais le ridicule ne tue pas je suis
encore en vie voilà donc à trois avec
moi 1 2 3
bien bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo
eh bien vous venez d'expérimenter de
rire sans raison
le rire sans avoir besoin d'être heureux
vous avez changé votre météo intérieur
très certainement et vous avez
simplement décidé de cultiver votre joie
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu
mais
[Musique]